Nadine, thank you so much for joining
on 20 minute leaders
and so nice of you to give me this time
know you're a very,
very busy, so thank you
very, very happy to be with you
wonderful
so Nadine, you know, I've
done quite a few of these so far
with really extraordinary people
that I'm inspired by each one
I don't think they came across such
a non-linear career path as yours
from working with a leading
politician in Mongolia to Shaman,
which you're gonna explain to me what that
is it to a classical music in New York
and, you know, I can't
even wrap my mind around
can you please just give me a very
somehow
brief and short about what you've done and
what motivates you in doing these things?
yes
so basically,
there is a Danish philosopher,
Kierkegaard, who said that when you look
back at your life,
everything makes a lot of sense
the only thing is you have
to live it forward, you know
so at least for everything
quite a paradox
yeah
so for everything I've lived till now,
I can actually give you the logic
I can give you two types of logic
one is very simple
I've always tried to be authentic
I've always tried to hear what is it to be
me right now and to be aligned with it,
you know,
and so the answers to that question have
led me to different parts of the world,
to different types of
professions and experiences and
apprenticeships and so on and so forth
what does it mean being authentic?
I need to get to the bottom of that first
yeah,
there are so many ways of looking at it,
but it's kind of a it's an instinct
that you have inside of you that
when you feel like your your
being true to yourself
a feeling that I'm walking
the path that I ought to walk
and it's because it feels right to me
and not because someone else has said
that it's great, not because I'm trying
to please someone else,
not because I'm trying to,
you know, go after some addiction of power
or money or any kind of success,
which are all external things,
bottomless pits, which in any case have
never made anybody happy
for more than a few moments
so I'm going to try to not be
after those external things
but that feeling inside, when you feel,
you know, it's kind of vertical
you feel good
you feel inside
yeah, that feels right
ok
now Nadine
this is perfect because I am
I'm right at the
the age group where I'm
at the intersection of making career
decisions, I'm choosing a major in college
or I'm applying to different units in the
ADF or choosing internships and jobs
and we have these external forces
I feel that I'm I'm
fortunate to be able to go on a path
that and my parents are supporting me
and saying whatever you feel is
right to you go
but I'm seeing so many people around me
that are struggling with this dissonance
how can it even how can you even expect
people at least my age
to be able to go through that
inner path piece and not
succumb to the other pressures?
yeah, it starts with self-awareness
it starts with inner curiosity
you know,
basically, I started my true
true journey maybe let me tell you a
few words about my journey
and then I can answer your question really
so I grew-up in Paris,
which is such a privilege,
because you get exposed to so much
culture and intellect and richness
and I was a true product of the
french excellence educational system
I went to the equivalent
of the Ivy Leagues of high school,
prep school, business school, all of it
but I had something inside of me always
telling me you can't go
into the conventional
past like you're gonna die
it's my own instinct
you know, it's my own instinct of knowing
yeah
what is not you already
that's a good start, right?
yeah
and one day
one night I didn't sleep
and it just like I put everything together
and I was like, yeah,
I'm going to New York
I'm going to work in publishing
because I love history
I also studied history
New York is a free place where
you can discover who you are
you can explore
nobody cares
Ok a big shift, right
so that was my first one
and then, of course, then life happens
and it's not exactly what you think
and so that's what your question is like
I always believe,
like, you don't do destiny
you show up, you do your homework,
and destiny does destiny
you know, like you meet certain people
in ways that you could never plan
like you have all those sorts
of things like that
then direct you and I ended up moving
on and developing within a classical music
company,
which was back then the biggest portal
online for classical music
and also a record label
and I was 24 and I
was probably, wait wait wait,
so you got you went you came
to New York to do publishing and
yeah
and then at 24 my age
and then you
came to found the world's most popular
classical music portal online
yeah
ok
that's what I mean
you don't do destiny
you show up, do homework
you work hard
and there are all those things
that you cannot control of encounters
like I met this amazing man who was
also the lawyer for Ifsa Rohan
you know, the fashion designer
and was with them that we did that
and so
and I
went around the world and I was
supposed to so much and I learned so much
but in parallel to that,
I had this thing about the inner
curiosity, like I had to understand myself better
and I started that journey in parallel
in parallel
ok and I so I was very curious,
I was driven by that need and I ended up
meeting a number of teachers, you know
so let's call it wisdom schools
you know, people
we're old souls and teach you a lot
of deep things and philosophies
and spiritual is a terry traditions
I also ended up in therapy with someone
who had studied with Carl Jung
oh, wow
one of the biggest psychologists of all
time and was also one of
so I spent many years with him and
what her her mentor was Carl Jung
one of Carl Jung's right hands
that's incredible
yeah
and then at some point she thought
that I should take on her legacy,
I should continue her work
so I was also trained in that
woah
and in parallel to that,
I joined a drumming circle where we were
working with shamans
from around the world
and so you're asking,
what are shamans those
so in every single culture on Earth
yeah
before the operation of monotheistic
religions, for instance,
in each village, you know,
there was always a shaman
shaman is a word a Tungus word, which is
a tribe in Northern Eastern Siberia
Ok
so every time is not the words,
so it doesn't matter
but it was like someone who could usually
use drum or other things to go
into trance, to go to different
state of consciousness
ok
to access information useful
for the community, whether
the future or to heal and when they do
that through into an intensive
drumming circle or drumming ritual
well, in almost every tradition,
a drum is involved
but sometimes they take stuff, you know,
like ayahuasca you may
have heard ...
I heard about that yeah
after all
but anyway, so I wasn't for the record
I haven't tried it, but I've heard about it
ok
the point is that with drums
just the sound of drum because
it goes like your heartbeat
it kind of tunes down your left brain
and you can access more your right brain
if you want to put it
in those metaphoric terms
very quickly recap, what is the difference
between left and right, remind me
like a more intellectual,
you tone down the intellectual side
and you can more the creative,
craved, intuitive, you know,
like all those other things
wonderful
and that was so you see ahead it was
amazing to work with those shamans
from all those different
traditions and native Americans,
Siberians,
and all this because
they still have a connection to nature,
to the elements, to the wisdom of life
that we're often
lost in the western world
so it was very enriching
so put all those things together
and all those currents have formed me,
you know, and at some point
wow
after six years in New York,
it felt like I was done
and the guidance came in a shamanic
journey that to become
who I'm meant to become
I have to move to Mongolia
and
I had never thought in my life
that I would do that
and it sounded quite insane
but I had this if I can imagine myself
going to my parents and my girlfriend
and saying, guys, you know,
I've been in Palo Alto for a while
I love the startup world
but to be who I really want to be,
I have to go to Mongolia
yeah, exactly
and a part of me was
saying exactly the same
but then there were so many coincidences
and I it was like just
so insane, you know
and it felt like yeah I have to do this
and I started doing a lot of homework and
I ended up in Mongolia thinking,
I'm going to be trained in shamanism or
something, because that's a place where
those traditions are
still very much there
but two days after my arrival,
I met this amazing, amazing human being,
Oyuun, who was back then the leading
female politician of the country who was
in college that had just won parliamentary
elections and gradually I
became her right hand
so I was in government
I was seeing how the government works,
the parliament I was working
in the Mongolian parliament
you were working in the
Mongolian parliament, too
and you met her two days after coming
to Mongolia to to be more
equipped with a shaman ritual
exactly
so, you see, that's what life is
you show up, you do your homework
I had done a ton of homework to know
so many people in Mongolia
but I could have never planned
to end up having the Mongolian soldiers
saluting me every morning and every
evening was when I was entering
the main building of the country
Nadine
you have to come to this
to the experiences as open minded, right
because I'm sure that in the same token
that you had these experiences,
you could have missed them
if you weren't open to accepting
them as another case
exactly
that's what I'm saying
you show up
yeah do your
homework and destiny does destiny
you know, so you're open
but also you look what feels right
what doesn't feel right
I feel its like dialogue between your
intuitions and things
that flow in your life
you know, I think what he called you
called a synchronicities, you know,
when there are weird coincidences
and you're like, wow, I should really
look in that direction, you know
ok, so Nadine just to make
sure that I'm following the track
let's recap
so Paris businesses like business
and Ivy Leagues and everything great
and then you move
to New York for publishing
but you actually go to create a musical,
a classic music portal, but then you
fall in love with the shaman rituals
so you go to Mongolia to
study that but you actually
and and somewhere in the process,
there where you study with Carl Jung's
right
right hand person and then
you end up leading with a politician
meeting a female politician
I always loved politics
I always I studied
international affairs also
so, you know, you can't
take things literally
shamanism is about accessing information
to transform reality and one way to do it is
through politics and development of policy
and I love it
so
so, you know, from that angle,
she said to me all over Asia to represent
her or Mongolia, which was hilarious
I spent time in Siberia, in Central Asia
we were in North Korea,
all sorts of adventures
what did you say about North Korea? we
were official guests for some celebration
you know, it was like not
not inside North Korea
yeah
inside you went inside North Korea
but back then, a lot of people were
it was a period when they were opening up
well, you're the first person that I
met that got to be inside North Korea
so officially, I got what I what
I wanted from 20 minute leaders
no
but, you know, anyway, it was just like
an education and exposure to a lot of
a lot of things
and at the same time,
it's minus 40 in the winter
It's the coldest capital in the world
and at some point, I felt like, listen,
I can't stay for the rest of my life,
you know, trying to give everything
I have to help this country
It felt like something
had to move, you know
and again, I was like, but where next?
no idea
and then in one of the conferences where
Oyuun had sent me, I met a minister
in the Tibetan government in exile
you know, the government
in exile of the Dalai Lama
and he invited me to India
to a teaching of the Dalai Lama
and it just felt right to it with my next
one way ticket, one suitcase
let me go to India
one suitcase
yes
and then in India, again,
the guidance and from one thing
to another, I ended up in New Delhi,
the capital where I did
a couple of things
I actually developed my therapy coaching
practice
and I ended up
doing amazing, amazing, amazing work
it was fascinating
within the Indian culture,
within the Indian society
what what type of therapy was this?
well, it's
a combination of union, right
yeah
there is energy and spiritual practices
and business leadership strategy stuff
basically, it's one on one coaching,
mentorship, therapy, that combination
yeah, exactly
and I was working with a lot
of fascinating people in politics
and business, and design
and arts and all of this
and in parallel to that,
I had TV shows on national television like
I was doing a morning show
interviewing Indian personalities
on the meaning of life in New Delhi
yeah
I also had a weekly column was
interviewing every week another
personality on the meaning
of spirituality,
which was amazing and super interesting.
and I met amazing people like that
and I felt I mean, I
felt very much at home in India,
I resonated a lot with the the spiritual
you breathe spirituality
you breathe a different understanding
of life, which talks to me a lot
and it was just
an absolutely fascinating time
so, wow
and that's a place where I
thought I would always stay
but somehow life guided me differently
why am I not surprised
yeah
but I am in a different phase now
but I'm just giving you a different
apprenticeships I've had
and so I moved to California in 2012
and I mostly focused on my
coaching counselling work
basically, I, call it a joint journey
because it's not
coaching or therapy does it
I don't resonate with those
words so much I call it a joint
journey because it's
really a journey with another person
you know, it's in
with other person where
the tool box is rich you know it can be
depth psychology
it can be working with dreams to help you
understand what's going on inside of you
a lot of trans-generation
work because it
turns out we carry so much baggage
from the generations before us
and if we don't understand that,
we are controlled by that
and that's not a life well
lived authentically, you know
so trans-generation work
combined with the business stuff or
political stuff or media stuff,
and all of this comes into my work
I work one on one with people and then
with their companies when they own
a company, you know it depends
cases I work with people in Europe,
in the US, in India, wow
in Asia and the rest of Asia,
actually in Israel, a couple of people
so I'm mostly focusing on that right now
and
it feels wonderful
it's like the confluence
of all the streams of my life
yeah, there were some
Hawaii in there
right
if I recall correctly
yes
I wanted to make it short so I
between New York and Mongolia
all the synchronicities were
leading me to the big island of Hawaii,
which is the which has an active volcano
and where I went, you know,
like totally like a reset button
it was like a reset button
of all my Western life
I spent time next to the lava flows
it was
extremely powerful what I went through
at a very, very deep level, and
then it was like, ok, I was ready to go
how long were you there for?
less than a year
less than six months even
but it was
really, really powerful
ok, Nadine, this is just insane
I'm so sad that we have
about four minutes left
this is ok
you know what
let's make it easy
I'm coming now to you
and I'm looking for some free advice
and I I'd love to know, you know,
you've gone through so many experiences
and so many authentic experiences
I don't want to know how to be successful
I want to know how to be content
so give me and whoever else
would be interested in this
what are some of your earned
secrets after these experiences?
of of what is it mean to really be content
and be authentic in a very tangible way?
what can people do in the 21st century
when we're guided by all these
technologies and all of these, you know,
races to be to climb the ladder of success
at 22 years old?
How can we deal with that?
first of all, just to ask that question is
already it feels to me like a big chunk
of the work, you know,
just to be aware that if
you just race and race and race,
you know, as they often say,
it's like putting the ladder,
climbing the ladder, and then you
realize it's on the wrong wall
First of all, ask the question to me
one way
one easy way to ask that question
is to imagine you're 99 years old
ok
and I ask you,
what is for you?
was it a life well lived?
and you just imagine
was it a life well lived
and can you just imagine
what would it entail
at the age of ninety nine
for you to tell me, yes,
it was a life well lived
can we trust people my age to
have to think to have that
thought
well, that's my second point,
is that the answer to that will
change over time and that's too fine
the point is, ask the question
try to ask the question,
but ask it again and again, right
It's not asking one time
and that's it
yeah, you don't
have a definitive answer
no definitive answer
this is my second point
keep asking because it changes third
point and life is a mystery
so third point,
the answer to what is a life well lived
is gonna be very different inside of you
if you ask the one who talks about
everything you want to create
or invent as an entrepreneur
everything that you have like it that you
want to do for the world that could
impact your meaning for society
that's one type of answer
if you have a side in you, that's
like a child and just wants to play
if you only work, it's never going
to be a life well live for that side
so can we ask that side too,
third
if we ask the one we knew that might want
to create a family,
for instance, a life well lived the answer
has nothing to do with a guy
who is the entrepreneur inside of you
right,
or if I talk about a lover inside of you
who wants to have a gorgeous chemical
relationship with your partner
do you think it's gonna be the
same answer
as, again, the entrepreneur
or the child or the father
no
you're just complicating things
Nadine, it's just too hard
and give it
it's not hard at all
the point is, if you understand that
inside you
I'll tell you
and that's my my next point
that's where I'm going
that curiosity that I was telling
you about at the beginning to try
to understand yourself better
you have that curiosity about yourself
now, that's what's going
to lead you to authenticity
it's basically, can you take a flashlight
and go inside yourself,
can you discover those different facets
inside of you because they
have different needs
they have different messages for you
they have different fears
you know, they have different
modes of operating
I love it,
so can you explore that a little bit
and maybe inside of you does a rebel
who doesn't care about any of that
maybe inside of you there's
also an inner critic who's
also trying telling you are not
good enough not good enough, or whatever
there's a hermit who just
wants to explore in the mountains
I have no idea
but can we take a flashlight,
explore that
because if you do that
you get to know yourself a little bit
more
so, by definition, it's more
authentic, the life you need
I love it
you see what I mean
no, no 100 % interesting
but I'm also aware that it has
to be some sort of balance where,
you know, I wouldn't want
my future 14 year old daughter
to come to me and say, daddy,
now I'm dropping out of
of ninth grade because my inner
self says that I should go and
and to do something else,
right
so, I mean, I do
think there should be some balance where
we have a path
that gives us the tools to be
able to think critically and be
successful in whatever we do
and and you obviously did a lot
of that before
you went on to experience.
do you think that's valid or should we
also entertain for much younger
people who feel that way?
actually, for me, though,
so I've developed a tool I called
a round table of inner characters
because I've found that most people have about
ten or twelve of those characters
all of us
ok
but at the head of the table is
lewis round, meaning it's equal
and I want to make sure I
hear from everyone, ok
The doer, the lover, the caretaker
all of them
yup
me at the head of the table
is what I call the wise one
ok
the wise one is the one who has a
sense of balance, has a sense of
yeah
it's not about quitting everything
and jumping and taking a one way ticket
and one suitcase and going
to the North Pole
you know, that has its limitations
the wise one is gonna find a balance
between certain drives,
certain intuitions, you know,
certain ideas, certain instincts
and that's the only one
that can actually synthesize all of it
and do something that is actually not
insane that will help
you walk that path for life
well lived
so much inspiration
I just love this talk so much
thank you for the time
I have to put you on the spot once
and I know it's not fair
but I will
I want you to tell me three words
that you would best describe yourself
I usually I say I am an explorer
so definitely, I'm an explorer
that's that's an easy one
a couple of others I have to tell,
you now?
we can do this later,
but I think that everybody would like it
just having gone through
this all these experiences
I mean I mainly interested
what type of personality leads
people to do what they do?
you know, a lot of entrepreneurs
are telling me they're passionate
A lot of CEOs are telling me
that they're empathetic and they're
sensitive to other people, their leaders
a lot of creative people say
that they're artistic and and etc
are obviously an explorer
what else?
what else how else would you characterize
it or how else would your
colleagues characterize you?
well, since I was little, I was
talking to people much, much older
than me about the meaning of life
a philosopher?
so you can say a philosopher or a priestess or
something like that about the seeker
ritual side, you know, a spiritual side
wanting to go deep, really deep,
as deep as possible
so it's about the wisdom, you know
so that's a very real art to me.
and then,
yeah, the third one,
I'll tell you next time, huh?
that's that
you know, and I think that
it's also amazing how, you know,
sometimes they get answers very quickly,
as if it's rehearsed
and people know it
sometimes it's very it's
very, very difficult
and I think that shows a part of it,
this inquisitiveness and this not being
willing to settle for a definitive
characteristic, but being
constantly under exploration
and I think having only two out
of the three is a part of the journey
that you're on to continue exploring
and I'm learning from that
because I think we truly, truly,
truly are a mystery in so many ways.
I love it
and it keeps unfolding
Nadine, thank you so much
I really appreciate it
you're welcome